ich bewege mich ich bewege mich wirklich
es ist so packen langsam
hallöchen freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen minecraft
gehabt natürlich schon sehr lange drauf
gewartet ich habe euch auch richtig
lange zappeln lassen sage ich mal
ich habe damals schon gesagt was so ein
paar sachen sein werden die ich
vorstellen werde und zwar wird es
diesmal einen minecraft guide sein wo
eventuell schon ein paar eingefleischte
minecraft wie sich das andere schon
bescheid wissen werden zu den fakten die
ich euch heute vorstellen werde
allerdings werde ich euch das trotzdem
versuchen so ein bisschen näher zu
bringen ich hab jetzt mal den schläger
eingepackt ihr habt schon den sieg
vorstellungen gesehen läuft alles
perfekt bin nur gerade wieder am
übertragen von den neuen gib ihm die
sachen für steffen deswegen kann sein
das ist ein bisschen ruckelt allerdings
ist das eher folgen natürlich alles kein
problem und zwar die erste sache ich
gehe sofort hin gaylord null und zwei
kinder die pilzköpfe
die treten natürlich nur in den maschen
billionen auf allerdings wenn ihr
schüsseln dabei habt könnt ihr einfach
auf diese pilze draufgehen und einfach
mal rechts weg machen und dann habt ihr
eine schüssel und da ist dann sogar was
drin also da ist denn der inhalt gefüllt
und die könnt ihr dann essen wenn ich
jetzt hier so ein bisschen rum jump oder
warte wenn ich mir hier so auf einfache
wenn ihr diesen shampoo wisst ihr
natürlich man kann die pilzsuppe messen
damit man da den hunger wegkriegt et
cetera pp
vielleicht passiert das in der zeit noch
aber ich denke ihr wisst alle dass das
mit dass man mit pilzen halt das
aufhören kann genauso wie mit schicken
etc
jedenfalls kann man ja schüsseln ansicht
stecken wenn man die allerdings einfach
so drauf klickt man immer wieder neue
man kann auch bei einer kuh so oft
draufklicken wie man will und diese
schüssel und kann man dann nichts denken
das ist irgendwie doof finde ich weil
ich finde die könnte man eigentlich auch
stecken und dann kommen die dann wenn
man davon alleine gegessen hat kommen
die dann wieder hier drauf weil ich
verstehe diese sache nicht gebratenes
fleisch kann man's decken und
ungeplanten das fleisch auch aber hier
kann man irgendwie volle schüsseln
pilzsuppe halt nichts denken ich weiß
nicht warum aber naja pilz ob mal haben
alle voll mittel kommen
so kommen wir zurück zur zweiten
änderung bzw
das heißt warten sie zurück zweiten
runde also kommen wir zurück kommen wir
zur zweiten sache die ich euch zeigen
möchte so ich bin jetzt auch einfach zu
faul das auszuschneiden weil ich gerade
schon am dritten tag wenn das irgendwie
auf zunehmendes vermische ich einfach
alles ist ja auch egal wir sind ja nicht
im während den wir nehmen auch bei
youtube
jedenfalls ist die zweite sache dass im
netz fließt die lava 7 blöcke statt vier
und die fließt auch viel viel schneller
das ist mir aufgefallen und zwar wenn
ich jetzt einfach eine lava setze ich
hab das extra so markiert da dauert
schon jahre bis sie dann mal endlich
hier an der maximalen ausbreitung
angekommen ist und da habe ich das hier
schon so abgegrenzt mit diesem goldenen
kuppeln da bis dahin fließt wenn ich
jetzt allerdings mich in den äther
bewege falsche seite da also richtige
seit ich hab ich das nämlich auch schon
abgegrenzt sind wir ein paar fehler wenn
ich jetzt einfach eine lava hinsetze
seht ihr schon es geht sehr sehr sehr
sehr schnell und die lava ist direkt
ausgebreitet und direkt sofort 47 blöcke
ich kann euch das mal ganz kurz nochmal
abstechen hier 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 also da
war der anfangs block der lava und das
hier sind dann sieben quasi und na ja
also das war die zweite sache die ich
euch zeigen möchte ich muss das hier
gleich alles noch schön aufräumen dort
wird erhalten spaß weil lava aufzurollen
da muss man immer alles voll bauen und
na ja also das war auf jeden fall
erstmal die zweite sache tcdd und da
sind wir bei der drehten sache die ich
euch vorstellen möchte und zwar erkennt
es ihr lauft über ostern und ihr seid
auf einmal komplett langsam ich kann ja
auch wenn er fünf gehen
ich schleiche hier die quasi schon
drüber die sonne blendet mich hier gut
so ein bisschen die würde ist nicht so
schön wisst ihr was noch unschöner ist
ich habe extra diese diese gold nichts
vorgelegt damit ihr wisst da hast das
und hier also da ist gold block geht
runter und hier ist es egal was darunter
ist jetzt noch es drunter und wenn dann
noch runter ist dann ist man noch
langsamer ich denke man sieht ohne dass
ich den vergleich mache wie bei der
kripo explosion man sieht ich bin total
langsam
auch wenn ich sprinte dauert es jahre
bis ich hier drunter bin dann bin ich
hier und dann sprinten schnell weiter
dann bin ich hier und dann springe ich
jedoch relativ schnell noch drüber wenn
ich allerdings fiel dann auch noch genug
drüber gehe und was ich mich auch noch
frage wenn ich dabei auch noch ein
schwert in die hand nehmen
reisen schwer dass er relativ egal und
dass er noch zur seite machte uns nieke
dann ich bewege mich ich bewege mich
wirklich
es ist so karten langsam
das ist unglaublich wenn ich jetzt das
mal weg nehme mich schon stücken
schneller wenn ich aufhöre ist mit
minimen stücken stelle und wenn ich
jetzt noch sprinter dann bin ich auch
noch ein bisschen schneller
aber wenn ich dann so mache dann bin ich
so packen langsam ohne witz wenn es
davon mal in wettringen geben würde
über zehn blöcke dann hätte man schon 20
minuten voll das wäre unglaublich das
ist so heftig mannes so packen langsam
dass es echt krass wo freunde im echten
leben blendet mich jetzt die sonne ließ
genau grat zwischen sonder spalte
baumhaus das ist unglaublich die wende
mich direkt in die fresse ein paar das
es nicht so schön hier blendet nicht
auch schon die sonne also das wissen
sondern 'inception' dingsbums jedenfalls
kommt zum fun fact of wieder gewartet
habt und zwar diese ändern and sound
hierüber ich muss erstmal wieder
vergessen hier wird das hört
diese endermann sounds sind in
wirklichkeit haltet euch fest menschen
stimmen menschen stimmen langsam
rückwärts manchmal auch ein bisschen
höher gestellt also die höhen tiefen
bisschen verstellt beste kompressoren
drauf aber meistens wirklich einfach
rüber und tiefer oder halt mal rückwärts
und zwar ist das einfach so etwas wie
hey mein gott wie geht's auch wenn man
fein rückwärts ist fein ein bisschen
schneller das ist dann irgendwie sowas
wie breit keine ahnung also das sind auf
jeden fall menschen sounds die einfach
nur rückwärts abgespielt der krämpfe
oder weil wir die mal ärgern können wir
doppelt dorn voll machen aber nähe kommt
dass lassen und nichts getan
das war also der fun fact die sonne geht
das gerade weg wenn ich mit dem video
auf höhere das ist super timing von mir
wieder gewesen so so wie ich jetzt aus
so bin ich wieder in der sonne
das war ein video für alle die jetzt
heute am ersten mal vielleicht doch
nicht unterwegs sind vielleicht einfach
keine freunde haben oder total hacker
gerade vom laptop sitzend wissen was er
machen sollen ich bin auf jeden fall
gerade auf dem fahrrad also kann
deswegen nicht auf kommentare eingehen
morgen weiß ich noch nicht ob im video
kommt ob ich mich dazu in der lage fühle
vielleicht aber auch einfach zu viel
milch getrunken und habe dann irgendwie
da kriegt man zu viel milch dieser
länder männer den spot da wir ja auch
noch blöcke wenig mit dem muss ich noch
mal reden
jedenfalls würde mich erstmal sehr
freuen wenn den video einfach einen
daumen hoch geben würde das wird mir
zeigen dass euch das ganze gefallen hat
und dass er eventuell mehr
minecraft geils haben wollte weil es kam
eine lange zeit einfach keiner dazu
einfach weil ich viel stress mit schule
hatte aber jetzt habe ich diese woche
zum beispiel schon drei freie tage
gehabt ich habe nächste woche einmal
drei tage frei das also ganz ehrlich mir
dich crazy daisy gut vom stuhl locker
vom hocker jedenfalls man vielleicht ein
paar videos für euch könnte mir einfach
in die kommentare schreiben ob er davon
mehr wollt und dann einfach ein daumen
hoch geben das zeigt mir das schon oder
halt weitere facts einfach in die
kommentare schreiben
und dann bin ich sagen sehen wir uns
beim nächsten mal wieder